c'est quoi la plus grande peur de votre
vie la plus grande peur que vous ayez
eue dans votre vie vous ça castagne nice
alors moi j'étais en fait j'ai dû me
faire opérer des sinus
j'étais à l'hôpital sinus et sinueuse
l'axé sinistra caussinus si lucho sinus
voilà et donc je descends au bloc et on
me dit on va vous rasez non et je dis
vous allez me raser quoi parce que c'est
en fait c'est ici les sinus sais pas et
en fait j'étais dans le mauvais bloc et
juste avant qu'il ment dorment ils
voulaient me fait en fait que m'opérer
des hémorroïdes
je vous jure que c'est vrai mais vaut
mieux ça c'est ah ça oui c'est la plus
grosse peur régnant kalaba ouvrant des
comptes du culte n'est rien moi j'ai eu
peur des agressions mais curieusement ma
plus grande peur c'est lié à mon fils on
était dans le métro parce que c'est une
peur totalement irrationnel on était
dans le métro je le tenait par la main
c'était l'heure de la cohue
je suis entré dans le métro et il ya des
gens qui sont passés entre nous et je
lui ai lâché la main et la porte s'est
refermée avant de monter dans le train
il est excellent comme il a vécu à l'âge
de 4 ans non mais semble donc il est
resté sous châtelet et moi je continuais
se continuer juste avant l'épreuve vais
pas tirer le truc là y'a pas parce qu'on
n'a pas le droit et pas lésés je me suis
précipitée et dieu merci des agents
s'étaient occupés de lui est nommé
embarqués et mon petit bonhomme n'est
fait salopette
mais les petites grandes soeurs sont
toujours liés aux enfants c'est vrai que
moi un soir c'était à eau pendant
spéciale de deauville je rentre dans ma
chambre d'hôtel sarah jane un homme non
j'étais venu avec mes filles et leur
mère et je vois leur mère dans la
chambre je vois pas les filles à côté la
grande adorent mettre dans la pièce à
côté et je vois pas la petite la petite
de 4 on que vous connaissez tous la luna
elle avait elle avait disparu donc 3
heures du matin donc on a appelé à la
réception au savoir
alors non je viens la réception les
caméras ne fonctionnaient pas rien de ce
qu'on appelle les flics on appelle des
fleet les flics débarquent et pendant 24
minutes j'ai cru qu'on avait enlevé
mafia
[Applaudissements]
et ben alors en fait elle avait roulé
sous le canapé où il y avait ça
d'épaisseur je me permets mais c'est la
paix c'est vrai mais alors c'est non
merci mais sur une malle vendus mais
attend avec votre voyage vous avez perdu
un enfant dans une de mes pensées c'est
grave mais là là là c'était pas le cas
et franchement l'histoire sur mes idées
parmi ses camarades la pensée de
l'histoire dégueulasse bailly n'est ce
pas
oui mais avec vous moquez promis de
venir bah c'est pas imaginer dit il ya
deux ans j'avais lu a pas une coupure de
presse me disais vous aviez arrêté tpm p
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je veux qu'ils aient une bonne histoire
moi c'était notre ascenseur il ya trois
mois
pourquoi de claustrophobie mais pour
cause de kaka phobie alors venez pas de
conneries 1,6 avec toulon mais ça les
good news
ouais ouais ouais récupérer les images
c'est ça ta plus grande peur est bien
sûr le mec il arrivait j'ai l'impression
qu'il avait une bombe à l'intérieur
bah oui oui de la peau 5
vas-y maxime a tout à l'heure vous allez
au comptant s'est rompue suis pas bien
du coup j'ai une petite gastro là je
suis désolé jared diouf
si je te lâches des cas cela je suis
désolé
[Applaudissements]
énorme action peur géraldine une vipère
qui s'est infiltrée dans les valises non
cet été c'est ouf j'ai posé sorte de
gros sacs de plage comme ça après de la
voiture il fait très chaud et la vipère
est rentré dans le sac sauf que je m'en
suis pas aperçu et quand je suis rentré
dans ma chambre d'hôtel j'ai posé mon
sac que la vipère est sorti et il est et
ouest et tard le soir et franchement
j'ai eu la peur de ma vie quoi les
studios
ça pique ça en fait j'ai hurlé s qui
sert à rien je suis monté sur le liste
qui ne sert à rien en prime et puis
finalement les sorties parce qu'on a
ouvert la porte
les gens s'étaient moqués c'était une
vipère qui faisait fort boyard des oui
voilà un truc de ce genre ouais du quad
en tunisie dans le désert on dormait
dehors et un moment j'ai senti un truc
qui me grimper dessus petite bête mais
bon j'ai d'abord c'était de leur beau
jeu top
j'allume évidemment et c'était un
scorpion transparent translucide non et
ce sont les plus dangereux évidemment
j'ai hurlé j'ai appelé le mac est venu
toucher pas ça c'est très grave portée
et sortent et là j'avoue que j'ai eu
extrêmement peu on était juste sur toi
ça va donner froid dans le désert donc
j'avais un gros trou d'une doudoune
mais j'ai quand même senti parce qu'il
commence à rentrer là c'est là
franchement ça m'a angoissé et même par
la suite j'ai eu la trouille grèce
souffre
linda merci